Welcome back home comforts.
Yo, yo, yo.
So what's the top the topics the Trinity
is
biblical? The Trinity is biblical. So
you going to use biblical verses to
prove the Trinity. Yes, yes,
the Bible I mean the yeah, the Bible
teaches the Trinity. Yes. Nice. So
how does three make one then? How does
three make one? Yeah. What is one times
three? Three. What is one to the third
power? You know what I'm trying to ask.
I got to do more specific than because I
just saw how three make one.
Okay, what's what's the difference
between counting humans and using the
same counting method to count God? What
would be the symmetry breaker?
Humans, there's like billions of those
and they're
about if there were three humans, bro.
Uh-huh. Yes. Okay, so you have the three
humans, human beings, and then there's
only one divine being. Would you agree?
Three human beings there's only one
divine being. Yeah, so there's you have
three human beings. You're saying human
beings, right? We all share the human
nature. That means there's one nature.
Yeah, you have you have like nature, but
you guys there there will be three
different humans and here's why. Because
you guys would be divided by time and
space, right? You guys are divisible.
The human being or the human nature is
divisible. Time and space so there could
be multiple human beings. Correct? Bro,
I think you're not understanding. So if
there were three human beings, right?
Three human beings in your house and
there were three gods in your house. So
there was a Trinity in your house. Where
are you getting three Where are you
getting
just an analogy. You don't have to go
into detail, but just for for you to
understand.
At least the analogy has to
The analogy has to fit what we're
talking about, dude. Okay, bro. Like
forget the house then wherever.
No, no, I'm I'm saying in in the house
there's three human beings. There's
three human beings. I got you. Three
human beings.
Yeah. Okay. Now when it comes to divine
beings, there's only one divine being,
right? So there there would only be one
divine being in the house, right?
Listen, that's not even what my question
was. My question was how do you If you
can't If you use the same counting
method, how do you count How do you not
count three humans the same way you
would count three gods? That's my Sure.
Because three humans are divisible and
divided by separated by space and time.
God is not. So the persons that share
the divine being since they're not split
by time and space, they're indivisible,
it's one divine essence, one divine
being as opposed to the human beings
that are separated by space and time so
you can count three of them. So when you
say essence, how do you define it as? Uh
your ontology, what you are. Yeah, so
what you are. So So we're all Okay, so
what you are.
So we're all one human. No, we are not
all one human. We we you and I are two
different humans. We're two different
human beings. So
I mean I This is so confusing. You can
You can explain it a little bit
a little bit better for everyone in the
audience as well. I think No, everybody
gets it. We all get it. What Just tell
me what what part is confusing to you
maybe.
I'm just trying to understand what is
the symmetry breaker if you're counting
three humans who share one human nature
and three gods who share one divine
nature. Why are we
Why Why are you Why are you Stop. Stop.
That part right there. Why are you
throwing in three gods? Who said that?
Because Jesus is God, Holy Spirit is
God, and Father is God. That's three
gods.
That is That is the divine nature being
predicated to the persons, not three
different gods. When you say that the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit are
literally call them three different
gods. When did I do that?
You know what? Oh, so so he's not God.
Forget that. Let's I can play this game,
too. You believe in 99 gods. You You
literally said that earlier. They're
just the names for the same person. What
are you talking about?
no, but you you said that there 99
different gods. You literally said that.
I literally never said that though.
What? I thought we I thought that's what
we were doing. I thought we were No, but
but that is literally I thought that I
thought that we were just like
misrepresenting each other purposely and
lying about what each other say. I
thought that's the game we're playing.
No? Okay, bro. That's completely
different example, but okay. Oh, I I
just thought we were I was trying to you
know, hop on what you're doing. So you
don't You didn't say that you believe in
99 gods? No. Oh. Did I say that I
believe in three gods?
Not in this conversation. Thank you,
bro. Thank you. I appreciate you being
honest. So
Can I ask you I just want to ask you one
last question. So the one God that you
believe in, is he begotten? So when you
I'm glad that you just did that.
Yes or no, bro. Hold on. Hold on. I'm
about to teach you something. I'm glad
you just did that. I'mma do this for the
audience, too. Just say yes or no, bro.
Guys, matter of fact, can you ask your
question one more time? Watch it Watch
what he does here, guys. The one God
that you believe in
The one God that you believe in, go on.
Is he begotten?
Is he begotten? If you say no, well,
then Jesus isn't God because he's
begotten. If you say yes, then the
Father is not God cuz he's unbegotten
and your Trinity is incoherent. Yeah, it
is.
Yeah, right? And so this is what It's
not just him. He didn't make this up.
This is coming from the Dawah scene, the
Dawah squad. And so what they do is is
they act as if the word God is univocal.
Meaning that it can only be used in one
way in one sense. So when they say, is
the one God you believe in begotten?
Well, stop them in their Stop them in
their tracks and call them out for their
deceptive tactic and say, hold on a
second. You are conflating categories
when you're talking about the word God.
Because the word God can be used as an
identity or it can be used as a
predication meaning talking about the
nature. So when he says, is the one God
that you believe in begotten? What do
you What he needs to understand is that
what he's asking is, is the one God that
you believe in begotten? How are you
using the term God? Are you using it
referring to the nature or referring to
identity? Bro, I'm just referring to
God, bro. In what way? You You
understand that the word God can be used
in multiple different senses, right? So
if I were to say If I were to say that
God is begotten, I'm using the word God
in the in the category of personhood.
I'm identifying the Son as God who is
the person of the Trinity who is
begotten, not the other persons. Bro,
the one God that you So See, I know.
See, I I I just busted your game.
Listen, one though. One what?
They're all one being one God, right?
wait. There you go. They're one being.
I'm I'm I'm One God.
your position.
I'm representing your position. Mm. What
do you want me to ask? Or is the person
of the Godhead Is Jesus the person of
the Godhead? Is he begotten? Is that
what you want me to ask? That's the
question you should ask. That's Why
though? Because you believe in one God.
Hold on, home comforts. That's what you
would ask if you were trying to honestly
intellectually engage with me. But
because you're trying to trap me and
play a game, you do it deceptively and I
I trust me. You're not the one who made
this up. We've seen this before from the
people you get this from and they've
been busted. So it's it's it's okay, you
know? But if you were honest, you would
ask is the person of the Godhead, the
Son, is he begotten? And that's would be
the answer. Yes. The person of the
Godhead. So the part of the Trinity
God the Son is begotten.
of the Trinity is begotten.
Oh, see
Yeah, yeah, y'all see what he just did
there? So the So the part So a part of
the Trinity is begotten. He's trying it
again. You're not engaging with
integrity, man.
Bro, I'm not I'm not even trying to trap
you. I'm just asking simple
you're you're purposely You're purposely
saying, oh, this is the Dawah script.
This is this stuff, but but you
literally not answering. Yeah, you're
you're you're purposely You're purposely
misrepresenting our belief. You're doing
it and like sneaking it in. But you're
going to get called out for everything
you do. Everything you do. You're going
to get called out for it. Huh?
Okay, bro. You're You've not even
answered anything, but okay.
I didn't answer anything? So If I didn't
If I didn't answer anything, what did
you understand from the response I gave
then? Since you're you're saying Yeah,
you want me to rephrase my question?
wait, wait, wait. Stop. Stop. You're
saying that I didn't answer you. Well,
listen, my my Pardon. Break down my
response if you can, my brother, please.
Yeah, you talked about the essence and
and you you talked about the fact that
this is the Dawah script and you talked
about the fact that you're trying to
trap me.
What was my response in in in how you
asked the question? How did I respond?
It was It was you you were making a
distinction between it being a
predication and
um an identity.
individual And and an identity, right?
Yeah, exactly. That's That's what you
said. So I did answer your question. I
showed you how you I showed you how
Yeah, I I answered your question, bro.
Yeah, no, that was a very clear answer.
It was. Um and then my point anyway is
is the fact that um you know, the reason
why you can't answer it by yes or no is
because you believe in three gods.
That's why. If If that wasn't the case,
then you'd easily be able to answer
simple simple questions to do with your
doctrine. Is that right?
Without actually wanting to change my
question and without actually trying to
change my question, but Okay. How many
creators do you have in Islam? What do
you mean how many creators? No one
equivalent to God. How many creators do
you have in Islam? See, if you if you
believe in If you believe in a creator,
they If you believe What do you mean If
you believed in one creator, if you
believed in one creator, you can easily
just say one creator, but see because
you can't is because you're a
polytheist. You believe in multiple gods
and multiple creators. Listen, that's
That's completely different.
Why? The two why? I said before. Why?
Because because I literally just told
you there's no one equal to him. Wait,
wait, but hold on a second. Well, if I
asked you how many crea If I asked you
Hold on, hurts. Hold on. Hold on, bro.
Looks like I got to just mute you now. I
didn't think that I had to do this, but
I got to do this. So when I give you uh
a full response that's not a yes or no
exposing your deceptiveness, your
deceptive tactic, and giving you a
correct and adequate response to your
answer that you can't deal with, and so
you got to shuffle and just attack. You
You say, "Oh, I can't give a yes or no
because I believe in multiple gods, or
else I would have been able to just say
yes or no." So, then when I ask you a
simple question, let's Hold on. I'll let
you talk, trust me. When I ask you a
simple question in return, and I ask
you, "How many creators are in Islam?"
You can't just simply say there's only
one creator, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, the greatest. You
believe in
Wait, but but but you would be able to
easily answer this if you didn't believe
in multiple
Well, only one ultimate creator, so
there's lesser creators? Yeah, of
course. So, then Allah's not the only
creator?
No, but no one's equal. I never even
affirmed a position. Oh, man, you're
You're polytheist. You believe in
multiple The equal question The equal
question to my question would have been
Oh, is is God begotten? You can ask me
the same question. No. No. I I wanted to
ask I wanted to ask you something that
was pertaining to your belief, and it
looks like you have multiple crea-
You're You're polytheist. You said that
there's multiple creators. Allah's them
the ultimate
Yeah, there's one ultimate creator, then
you said that there's lesser creators.
You're polytheist. I mean
I mean we're all creators. We can all
create something. We're all creators?
Yeah, but that's How is this the same
answer or question that I even asked you
about? I asked you about God
specifically. You're trying to bring in
I asked you about God specifically, did
I not? No, you didn't. Really? So, You
asked me about creators. You asked me
about anyone to be a creator. I asked
you I thought Allah was I thought Allah
was unique.
I thought he was the only creator. I
thought he was the only one. I You know
what? I I cuz I think I wrote this down,
but I got to get this again. We are all
creators. We're Allah's the ultimate
creator. We are lesser creators than
Allah. So, there's multiple crea- You're
polytheist. How How does that mean I'm a
polytheist? Because you believe in
multiple If you ask If you ask Allah
what day is it today, and if you ask me,
and if you both give the same answer,
does that mean he's he's equivalent to
me? No. So, what's your point? I mean, I
already answered you without going into
essence and predication and everything
that nobody understands. What's today's
date? It's April April April 2nd. April
2nd. Just hold on a second for me,
brother. Just be a little patient with
me. April 2nd.
Um
Allah is the ultimate creator, and there
are lesser creators, including us. If
this isn't shirk, I don't know what else
is. How many creators of life do you
have? Creators of life? Yeah. No one is
through Allah's authority that anyone
can create life. So, how many creators
of life do you have? Well, directly,
Allah's the only one who creates life.
Didn't Jesus create life directly? No,
but my belief is that obviously through
the Father's help, yes. Through the
who's He was given authority. Through
whose help?
All the miracles he did were through
help of God.
Wait, wait, you said you But you said
something specific. You said All All
prophets did miracles. Wait, you said
Through whose help? Through God's help.
not what you said. Say what you said
first.
Okay, bro. Okay, through the Father.
Oh, through the Congratulations. You
just got one over me, bro. So, Allah Is
Allah the Father? Well, the way you
describe him is the same attribute, yes.
You said yes? Well, you keep changing
topics. Look, you've shifted from
Dude, I
I promise you I didn't even You gave me
an analogy. You gave me an analogy or
something that's completely different to
the question I asked you.
even mean
even answer yes or no to the one true
God. You got to answer
Bro, I'm sorry. I did not mean to catch
you on that. My bad. I didn't mean to. I
I I
I was on something specific. My mind I
promise you my mind was on something
specific about the creator.
And then you said Father. I That caught
my attention. I'm sorry. Okay, bro.
Okay, because look at the topic. It's
biblical, right? So, I'm Biblical? This
is This is Quranic. You're a Muslim. You
have to You have to Okay, fine. Okay,
bro. Okay.
I saw Let's go Let's go back. Let's go
back.
Um so, Jesus created life with the help
of Allah, right? Yes. So, how many
creators do you have in Islam of life? I
just told you. He is the direct creator
of everything. Except this bird that
Jesus created. Bro, in Islam, we say
nobody is equivalent to him. I don't
care. Okay. What do you mean you don't
care? But you should care because that's
my position. So, everything else you're
saying, I already answered you with the
fact that You're missing it, bro. nobody
is equal. You're missing it. I I
understand. Look Look, unlike you, I can
accurately deal with your position, the
position you truly hold, and I can show
you how the tradition how the you know,
position you truly hold is inadequate.
Unlike you with me, how you misrepresent
my how you straw man my position, and
you try to argue against a straw man.
How How is it I can actually deal with
what you actually believe. For example,
I'm I'm I'm showing you. You believe
that there's nobody that's on the same
level of Allah, right? He's the ultimate
creator. That's fine.
That doesn't change the fact that there
would be a lesser creator, another
creator, but he's just lesser than
Allah. No worries. So, Jesus
I don't. You do. So, you So, you believe
No. No. Stop, bro. Relax. You said that
only Allah is the creator of life. Yet
we have Jesus creating life in your
Quran, right? Okay. So, how many
creators of life do you have according
to the Quran? Bro, just because he
indirectly created something doesn't
mean it wasn't through Allah anyway.
He's When everything exists because of
Allah's will, bro. No worries. Who
created that bird, though? I just told I
You're making me repeat the same thing.
I'm going to repeat the same thing I
just did. All right. When Jesus And you
believe in the same thing. You believe
in the same thing as I'll I'll say I'll
say it like this.
Jesus says, "I make for you a bird
from clay." According According to the
words of Jesus, who made the bird?
Listen. Listen, bro. When When the
prophets in your Bible do miracles,
right? Do they Masha Allah. Take care of
yourself, brother. Take care of
yourself. You came up here, you
humiliated yourself, you tried to use
deceptive tactics that you get from the
dawah guys. You got exposed, just like
they've been exposed. Stop learning from
them. Stop parroting them. Stop copying
them, and they will not have you out
here looking as dumb as you just did.
Come here humbly. Come here
respectfully, and you won't leave
embarrassed. How you doing, bro? How you
doing, Avery? Pretty good.